15 mai 2019 la chambre de l'instruction
de la cour d'appel de dijon rejette la
demande de non lieu dans la sphère du
meurtre de sylvie aubert tué en novembre
86 on continue quoi continue l'enquète
et je suis super contente
la chambre d'instruction a considéré qu'
il y avait au moins une ultime
vérification affaire qui était le
recours un fichier de rapprochement des
affaires criminelles qui s'appelle
salvac ce qui n'avait pas été fait et
donc elle a demandé à ce que cette cette
diligence soit soit effectué
le rejet du non lieu dans l'affairé
robert c'est le verre à moitié plein
mais les avocats de l'association
christelle eux sont en colère contre le
verre à moitié vide
nous sommes obligés de venir plaider
dans la chambre de l'instruction comme
dans robert pour qu'on ne ferme pas le
dossier qu'on poursuivre des
investigations alors que dans chacun des
dossiers il ya des pistes ya du travail
à faire
il ya même deux dossiers où des
personnes sont mises en examen depuis 20
ans on a des magistrats moi je pense
qu'à un moment donné il faut quand même
dire les choses qui ne travaille pas sur
ces dossiers qui n'ont rien fait pendant
des années sur ces dossiers et qui
finalement se satisfont d'avoir des mis
en examens de palets rechercher la
vérité autour de ces mis en examen c'est
incompréhensible pour les familles qu'un
rôle soltysiak était tué en novembre 90
en 2000 la presse donne cette affaire
comme résolu deux suspects sont mis en
examen
dix neuf ans plus tard ils le sont
toujours mais ils sont dans la nature et
l'enquète n'a pas avancé dans la sphère
vanessa tier l'on retrouvait dans la
saône en juin 99 un homme là aussi est
toujours mise en examen à ce jour en
2016 une exhumation demandé par maître
hermann a permis d'établir que vanessa
ne s'est pas noyé et n'avait pas pris de
stupéfiants
depuis le dossier n'a plus bougé à la
juge qui en a la charge la maman de
vanessa formule cette demande
et voilà et de jeter un coup d'oeil sur
le dossier de temps en temps connaître
ce qui s'est passé et qui qui est
l'auteur du crime
aujourd'hui les dossiers des meurtres de
saône et loire sont dans le creux de la
vague
pourtant après la condamnation des
meurtriers de christelle mairi et
christelle blétry toutes les familles
avaient repris espoir
mais on voit aujourd'hui que la
résolution de ces deux affaires a été
due à une conjonction de circonstances
favorables notamment des juges
d'instruction et des enquêteurs très
investis pour raphaël nedeljko
enquêteurs dans les dossiers mairi et
bletterie les affaires anciennes
requiert un travail policier très
particulier ce sont souvent des dossiers
qui ne sont pas marquées par de la
téléphonie de l'adn très très souvent
laissé les sons sont anciens ou à revoir
même sont détruits ce qui était le cas
dans la ferme agri voilà donc oui en
moyens il faut surtout des enquêteurs
déterminé et très peu de moyens un
ordinateur un véhicule et du temps
surtout énormément de temps il faut que
ses enquêteurs soit vraiment dédié à ce
travail sur ces dossiers anciens
j'ai la conviction et je les confirme et
avec le temps que tout est toujours
possible dans un dossier quel qu'il soit
quel que soit son ancienneté
pour l'heure aucun des sept dossiers
toujours porté par l'association
christelle n'est formellement refermer
certains ont frisé le non-lieu d'autres
ont été rouverts après avoir été classé
ce que la loi permet durant 20 ans en
cas de nouveaux éléments
mais quelle est la volonté réelle de la
justice concernant ces affaires
actuellement les dossiers
non élucidées bas doivent en quelque
sorte continuer à être être instruite en
tout cas tant qu'il ya une demande très
forte qu est le cas dans les affaires
cette affaire des familles on a bien
entendu la réserve
le procureur général fait dépendre
l'action de la justice
de la pression mise par les familles
alors que se passerait-il si
l'association christelle venait à
s'essouffler pour mettre ce ben hermans
et au contraire aux magistrats de
prendre leurs responsabilités
les délais sont trop longs mais on met
des années à faire des à nous accorder
des expertises des années à nous dire ce
qu'elle donne des années en tirer les
conséquences
vraiment c'est insupportable moi ce que
je demande à tous les magistrats
concernés par ces affaires c'est
reprenons notre souffle mettons des
enquêteurs sur ces affaires c'est
inacceptable c'est impensable qu'on
n'exploite pas jusqu'au bout les pistes
et qu'on fasse pas le travail il ya des
dd je pense d'aidé me retourner presque
sur le point d élucider les éléments
sont là il suffit qu'on se mette au
travail aujourd'hui de vieilles affaires
non résolues reste donc en souffrance en
saône et loire et les familles des
victimes
aussi parallèlement dans le même ressort
de la cour d'appel de dijon
l' affaire grégory elle continue à
mobiliser régulièrement juge et
enquêteur peut-être serait-il temps pour
la justice d'être un peu plus équitable
dans la répartition de ces moyens